[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute ein
richtig leckeres türkisches herzhaftes
Gericht und zwar ein Kartoffelpüree Bett
und oben drauf misket Köfte sind einfach
kleine runde kräftebällchen und ich
starte jetzt direkt mit dem
Kartoffelpüree dafür nehme ich mir meine
mehlig kochenden Kartoffeln es
funktioniert notfalls auch mit
vorwiegend festkochenden aber dann habt
ihr meistens noch so kleine Stückchen
die einfach nicht weich werden wollen
und dann nimmt am besten mehlig kochende
die machen auch einfach eine bessere
Konsistenz und ich nehme jetzt hier mein
Messer und schneide ganz vorsichtig
einfach nur an der Schale entlang falls
euch fragt wo stehen denn jetzt hier die
ganz genauen Zutaten Angaben die
schreibe ich euch ja immer ganz genau
auf die schreibe ich euch unten in die
Infobox wie immer so nachdem ich das
gemacht habe die habe ich übrigens
vorher schon gewaschen gebe ich sie in
kochen und Salz Wasser und werde erstmal
schön garen so und indem ihr hier ganz
fein an der Schale entlang schneidet
nicht zu tief das ist gar nicht
notwendig könnt ihr einfach später nach
dem Kochen die Schale ganz einfach
entfernen und spart euch vorab das
Schälen ihr könnt sie auch andersrum
abstehen und dann garen aber so ist es
irgendwie einfacher für mich
[Musik]
so während die Kartoffel garen kümmern
wir uns um unser Köfte ich habe jetzt
hier schon mal mein Hackfleisch dann
nehme ich rindergehacktes ich habe oft
fettarmes Rinderhack im Tiefkühler bzw
ich ich friere mir das immer ein aber
besser wäre tatsächlich wenn ihr auch so
ein bisschen Fett mit dran habt das ist
ja auch Geschmacksträger und ich nehme
jetzt hier einmal die Zwiebeln während
sie schälen und dann mit einer Reibe
direkt zum Fleisch schreiben da kommt
dann auch noch Knoblauch mit dazu Salz
Pfeffer ein bisschen Paprika Flocken
Pulli Bett die sind nicht mehr gerne bei
türkischen Rezepten und der Petersilie
darf nicht fehlen das kommt alles mit
rein und dann knete ich das mit den
sauberen hinten
[Musik]
bevor ich jetzt anfange zu kneten die
Bindemittel und zwar ein Ei und
Paniermehl damit Sie uns gleich in der
Pfanne nicht auseinander bröseln das
gebe ich mit dazu und jetzt alles schön
zu einer richtig feinen Masse kneten und
dann zu ganz kleinen Bällchen formen
[Musik]
die köftebällchen sind fertig und jetzt
nehme ich mir ein bisschen Öl gibt das
in die Pfanne und dann werden sie
richtig schön kross von allen Seiten
gebraten die brauchen auch nicht so
lange dadurch dass sie so klein sind und
sie kommen ja später noch mal in die
Soße da dürft ihr euch jetzt keine
Sorgen machen dass sie irgendwie nicht
durch werden oder sowas das auf jeden
Fall jetzt gebe ich das wahrscheinlich
in so zwei drei fuhren hier immer wieder
in die Pfanne und dann raus und dann
zeige ich anschließen wie wir die
Tomaten Paprika Soße machen
[Musik]
so in der gleichen Pfanne mache ich
jetzt die leckere typisch türkische Soße
dafür brauchen wir Butter einfach direkt
rein hier so ein bisschen Restfett das
ist auf jeden Fall in Ordnung und jetzt
nicht ganz so Hochschalten denn wenn
Butter verbrennt ist blöd kann man
direkt alles wieder neu machen und
Butter verbrennt doch sehr schnell da
kommt jetzt Tomaten oder Paprikamark
dazu ich habe Paprika mag ihr könnt aber
auch Tomatenmark nehmen ihr könnt auch
machen finde aber mit Paprika mag wenn
das ganze dann richtig schön diese
Röstaromen freischaltet das schmeckt
einfach noch mal auf einem anderen Level
gut und da kommt jetzt gleich nachdem
das so ein bisschen anderes durfte
Wasser mit dazu erstmal wenig bis ihr
die gewünschte Sämigkeit erreicht habt
und dann würzen wir das ganze ist eine
blitzsoße
[Musik]
bei den Gewürzen halte ich es jetzt sehr
einfach Salz und Pfeffer natürlich und
was ganz klassisch mit dazu kommt ist
Minze das ist so eine ganz ganz typische
türkische Kombination und da gebe ich
jetzt auch ein bisschen mit dazu eine
Münze ist immer so ein bisschen gröber
daher kann ich das einfach in den Händen
so ein bisschen reiben und dann hier
rein tun und ein bisschen Paprikapulver
edelsoße süß wäre es scharf macht der
kann jetzt auch natürlich Chili dazu
geben oder scharfe Paprika Flocken aber
ich habe ein bisschen Schärfe schon in
den Köfte Bällchen drin daher mache ich
jetzt hier erstmal ohne Schärfe und dann
kommen jetzt schon direkt unsere köfchen
zurück in die Soße und jetzt können wir
auch schon die ähm das Kartoffelpüree
fertig machen in die Kartoffeln die sind
fertig die habe ich gerade auch parallel
während das hier angebraten hat geschält
bzw mit den Händen einfach nur noch die
Schale entfernt und jetzt verarbeiten
wir das zu Püree
[Musik]
so die Kartoffeln dann nur noch mit
Milch und Butter stampfen das geht ja
ganz schnell und an der Stelle noch mal
würzen da gebe ich rein Salz Pfeffer und
Muskatnuss mehr braucht es nicht und
dann wird das Ganze serviert und das
Schöne ist hier dann wirklich isoliert
ist so hübsch und dann kriegt man direkt
Lust auf dieses Gerät dann ist auch so
ein Gericht das einfach jeder mag also
ich kenne mich niemanden der diese
Kombination nicht mag das verrühre ich
hier noch gut ich habe mir heute so
einen großen Teller genommen wir können
das natürlich auch portionsweise
servieren und dann einmal das Bett aus
Kartoffelpüree so einmal hier drauf
geben
und die könnt ihr so lange auch in der
Soße warm halten und ich verlinke euch
auch gerne mal meine Töpfe denn dort
bleiben auch Gerichte viel viel länger
waren wegen der guten Beschichtung und
dann gebe ich dir einfach nur noch
Petersilie drauf und das war's
[Musik]
und fertig ist unser köstliches Gericht
das ist echt so ein Rezept so ein
Gericht das mag jeder also ich kenne
wirklich niemanden aus der Familie der
das nicht mag macht es gerne nach und
schickt mir eure Fotos bei Instagram
oder bei Facebook ihr seid eher so bei
Instagram habe ich das Gefühl also
markiert mich dort gerne und hinterlasse
meinen Kanal ein kostenloses Abo damit
ihr solche genialen Rezepte auch nicht
mehr verpasst und dann sehen wir uns
auch beim nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]